on passe maintenant à notre therion du
samedi soir
[Musique]
l'idole à hémonstoir
[Applaudissements]
lie depuis votre plus jeune âge vous
êtes doté d'une intuition hors du commun
et aujourd'hui vous mettez ce don au
service de la police pour aider à la
résolution d' enquête criminelle vous
êtes en fait la seule femme profileuse
de france vous racontez votre histoire
dans un livre intitulé osé faire
confiance à votre intuition publié chez
michel lafon avant de commencer je
voudrais que l'on regarde un message que
vous avez posté lilly sur facebook le 22
mars gagne voilà c'est un message où
vous expliquer à des amis que vous
ressentez l'imminence d'un nouvel
attentat
et lorsqu'on vous demande à quel endroit
vous répondez dans le sud de la france à
marseille ou à nice
pour vous rien d'exceptionnel de
paranormal vous dites c'est plutôt
l'expression d'une extrême sensibilité
que vous avez appris à écouter vous
décelé dans l'inconscient des infos que
la raison ignore
d'ordinaire c'est ça avec ma sensibilité
effectivement cédé intuition qui sont
vraiment
développer et je décèle les événements
avant qu'ils arrivent depuis tout petit
alors vous êtes né le 10 novembre 1982 à
noisy-le-grand votre père est chef de
rayon dans un supermarché votre mère est
femme au foyer et jeunes filles c'est
vrai que vous êtes déjà hyper sensible
très empathique
quand éric un de vos camarades de classe
à des migraines vous le savez sans qui
vous le dit je les ressens j'ai mal à la
tête quand il a mal à la tête et je lui
disais tout petit là tu as mal à la tête
il avait mal mais pareil pour ceux qui
avait mal au dos ce qui était triste
qu'ils étaient en colère j'étais une
éponge en fait vous avez pas que vos
premiers signes de prémonition par
exemple quand le téléphone sonne vous
savez qu'ils appellent
avant que mamma mia plaisait dans la
voiture m'a bien rappelé études et qu'on
rentre et même les appeler ouais donc ma
mère remarqué qu'il y avait quelque
chose quelque chose d'inhabituel alors
en grandissant vos prémonition
deviennent plus pointus par exemple un
jour vous dansez avec une copine dans sa
chambre sa belle brenda le dollar afin
de faire les folles quoi on déconnait
est en fait vous voyez la maltraitance
ton brenda est victime ouais on danse on
se tient les mains et je ressens en fait
de la violence chez elle autour d'elle
et sur elle et ça me traumatise dont
j'en parle je descends et j'en parle à
ma mère dit il se passe quelque chose
avec brenda ça va pas avec sa mère
c'était vrai c'était vrai vous avez ces
temps quand un jour en sortant de
l'école vous annoncez à votre mère que
la maison brûle et en fait vous rentrez
chez vous effectivement les gars y avait
un feu dans un cagibi j'ai court circuit
dans la machine à laver il y avait un
début d'incendié
les huit ans quand vous rêvez qu'un
petit garçon a été enlevé et assassiné
par un homme vous voyez une maison
maison blanche avec des montagnes avec
des forêts autour vous voyez un homme
caressant un enfant dans une cave au
réveil vous racontez votre rêve à votre
mère vous l'a supplié d'appeler la
police et le soir au journal télévisé en
annonce le meurtre de fabrice dans une
maison blanche au milieu d'une forêt
après des abus sexuels
c'était la première fois que ma mère
réalisé que j'avais vraiment des
prémonitions et pour moi ça a été une
expérience extrêmement traumatisantes
votre mère vous dit que vous êtes médium
comme votre arrière grand mère en fait
oui ouais alors sauf que elle était
couturière que ça se disaient pas elle
avait des intuitions mais on employait
pas le terme médium vrai très tabou à la
descente j'ai littéralement débordés par
vos intuitions c'est pénible mais être
une éponge
c'est dur parce qu'on ressent toutes les
émotions on a l'impression d'être enfin
je culpabilise et de sentir ce que la
vie en fait d'eux des gens de donc ouais
c'était dur à l'âge de 24 ans vous vivez
avec votre copain je n'en ai pas alors
tout va bien mais soudain vous avez des
intuitions morbide vous rêvez qu'on vous
annonce que vous avez une maladie grave
et qu'on doit vous faire des injections
dans la tête en fait des examens
évidemment d'avoir des tas de toubib
rien j'étais sûr j'étais malade savait
pas de quoi mais je savais que j'avais
accès avait quelque chose et les toubibs
ou 10 en fait non vous avez rien soit je
faisais des infections urinaires
de manier les crises d'angoissé enfin
voilà y'a rien de précis tout le monde
vous proposez hypocondriaque et puis un
an et demi plus tard le diagnostic tombe
vous avez une tumeur au cerveau qui fait
22 mm quand même
on me l'annoncer à ce moment là je suis
au lieu de pleurer je me dis voilà ça y
est je sais ce que je fais maintenant on
va pouvoir me soigner vous avez ça dans
une zone très compliqué c'est très grave
on vous envoie en radiothérapie donc
pour éliminer cette tumeur au bout de
trois séances vous arrêtez ça me rend
malade jeu
j'étais pas véritablement malade à voir
je le sentais ouais donc ça me plaît pas
j'ai l'impression enfin je conseille pas
tout le monde d'arrêter mais moi je
n'étais pas prête encore dont je me suis
je vais prendre un peu plus de temps je
vais l'arrêté vous arrêter vous adresser
un magnétiseur et quelques semaines plus
tard vous êtes guéri c'est la vérité
soit c'est la radiothérapie et soit
c'est le mental soit si
vous décidez quand même de tout plaquer
jouant les pins le petit ami les études
de psycho vous décidez de mettre votre
don au service des autres vous montez à
paris bhl devenez coach de vie vous
travaillez un petit peu dans le monde
des médias lee fait des petits boulots
et un jour les standardistes dans un
centre dédié des activités psychologique
quand un policier vous appelle il est
énervé par le retard d'une praticienne
et pour le faire patienter vous discutez
avec lui lui demander sur quoi ils
travaillent
et quand il vous dit qu'une femme a
disparu qu'on n'a pas retrouvé le corps
vous est parcouru de frissons très fort
et soudain vous avez un flash un corps
calciné et puis je vois des flammes donc
automatiquement je lui dis faut chercher
dans la cheminée
je me dis mais comment vous savez
effectivement il
recherche autour autour du feu pourquoi
parce que il ya les voisins qui ont vu
un feu en fait une grosse fumée noire
est donc je lui ai dit il faut chercher
à côté d'un champ et là il me dit mais
bon ça avec un champ juste à côté et je
le sentais je peux pas l'expliquer mais
je la sentais et un mois plus tard le
policier vous annonce que des restes
d'une femme calcinées ont été retrouvées
effectivement sous un tas de ferraille
une autre fois vous êtes contacté par
une policière qui a entendu parler de
vous une famille entière a été assassiné
vous montrent des photos de deux murs
couverts de sang
elle arrive tout de suite comme si
j'étais préparé à ça montre des photos
avec énormément de sens
en deux chambres un salon
il n'y avait pas les corps mais il y
avait le sang c'était atroce je n'étais
pas préparée dont j'ai refermé le
dossier j'ai dit non je ne veux pas j'ai
pas j'ai même pas besoin des images et
vous voyez un jeune homme dont la
famille se méfie il me vient prénom même
et effectivement je ressens exactement
comment il l'a fait pour quelle raison
et je lui ai donné des
des éléments pour le faire tomber enfin
si je peux dire ainsi oui d'ailleurs le
gars finira par avouer alors le bouche à
oreille fonctionne vous recevez de
nouveaux appels et un jour un policier
vous propose de l'aider à résoudre des
enquêtes de façon plus régulière
j'ai de coopération dure encore
aujourd'hui vous lui faites part de vos
intuitions qui sont souvent bonne et ce
qu'il faut dire en fait c'est que tout
ça est à l'insu de la hiérarchie parce
que en france n'utilise pas en fait ces
talents pour la police plusieurs fois de
me faire participer officiellement aux
enquêtes s'est toujours refusée alors
qu'aux états unis en russe et en chine
c'est paris on travaillait pas pour pour
la police française alors que aux états
unis de travailler pour la cia houle ou
left behind j'aimerais serviable en fait
j'avais le potentiel en tout cas alors
il faut dire quand même que vous faites
ça sans aucune rémunération juste pour
rendre service alors désormais votre
réseau s'est agrandie vous recherchez
aussi bien quelqu'un qui vous dit mon
mari alzheimer il a disparu je le
retrouve plus il ya des gens qui
viennent nous voir parce qu'ils ont
perdu leur chat c'est vrai
j'ai pas toujours je vais pas toujours
retrouvées le chat mais c'est vrai que
en tout cas je j'essaie je demanderai à
mon retour
vous dites ce sixième sens en fait c'est
l'instinct l'intuition la prémonition et
on s'en sert tous les jours en fait même
nous on ne sait pas mais une maman qui
semble son enfant est en danger c'est le
sixième sens un joueur de poker qui se
disent un bon coup
c'est de la prémonition une femme qui
semble son mari est infidèle c'est
pareil sauf que chez vous s'est
exacerbée sur la présidentielle de 2017
vous avez une intuition
oui j'ai une intuition ce que je sais
que le président qui va être élu
sanaa laraque ce qu'on a eu jusque là
c'est très nouveau ça va tout changer et
pour du long terme
vous pensez que rage d'autres attentats
en france cette année puisque vous avez
été extrêmement prémonitoire sur
l'attentât nice
et on aura on le sait de toute façon et
chante rome vous voyez quoi un attentat
[Rires]
dernière question
est ce qui vous est arrivé de vous
tromper oui bien sûr l'erreur est
humaine
on se trouve parfois c'est parfois hyper
dur à porter parce que les gens nous
remettent même les enquêteurs tous leurs
espoirs sur le dos
mais après il va avoir tout de suite un
retour positif et ça repart merci de
votre témoignage
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux